say one it says I'm coming out loud and
clear
you guys set out you lied okay let me
try it better now a little bit damn now
uh D live better now yeah yeah a little
bit up god better now that's nothing
perfect yes good okay thank you me team
up with one of them and you team up
since we've been playing a game our o
give them a little bit better of a
chance hey we don't need your mercy
hey B makes we got this on lock all
right Mian makes it a pro team at me a
mix a means I mean links and I are gonna
do great I'm not leaving this goddamn
tent oh you're a hadn't shut up no oh
can I just run out with this race
I've got a grenade I've got a grenade
I've got a grenade got a grenade
Oh God me and makes the automated dead
links I'm gonna come for you I don't
think oh my god oh my god someone's
shooting who is that no I've got a guy I
got killed my song hums it makes where
are you I'm gonna die oh by default that
was hardly fair you guys you guys suck
oh he's owned me guys hugged me hey she
exchanged the pleasantries before
shooting each other in the face but you
know that's cool hey don't tell me how
to do my my video over here I don't know
about you to run things on your channel
Mike yeah why are you answering my phone
calls shoot you in the face yeah oh I
know you say oh don't ever try I'm a
professional I've got a grenade
oh shoot shoot shoot they're zombies
yeah suck them I actually died from the
thumb is Oh No yeah Bobby this ah we
didn't die that was cheap as you suck
and I hate this game go to hell
I am staying out of the way in this 1000
G I'll go this is a deal I flick Oh edgy
oh there you are
that's pretty no soul dude I've got a
fussy mark I can see marker cuz I know
you can't yes yes no I got an assist on
that I just saw the zombies running in
one direction and then I assumed
why is he asked - nothing yes lanes no
damn that's right you right if you it's
good if you right-click Oh dancing trash
game please oh oh please doesn't work it
didn't work go suck you have to let it
go [ __ ] you we didn't say that are we
going right now my colors it's ready
escape and work as a team as well I
think it's looking good footage no just
hold over seeing a lot of zombies that
yeah is it is that how it's pronounced
Nakia yeah really
so here in America called Africa
landmark eeeh
yeah was my heel I kind of fur it your
way
Oh nokia nokia yeah that's what we've
been running circles and I have not seen
anyone I'm just good I'm where you were
huh I'm a zombie rose
something's growling huh there's anyone
by a playset or her
it's like trouble and Terrace town hey
everybody anyway around anybody I'm not
a zombie perfectly normal
I'll make this into a hilarious montage
don't worry
uh-huh hilarious shut up huh
I'm not no I didn't mean anything by
that uh trying to play some I'm worried
doesn't mean I'm here your videos are so
good it's so good so good okay this time
mark I'm gonna kill you okay
personally really cuz I just I
criticized some batch yeah I've stopped
totally supportive makes your awesome I
think I think uh what's the two few
seconds yes if I see markers minx I'm
gonna leave leave Abby I wanna see how
this ends up you should you should come
to the bathroom I know where that is
thank you oh this to me there's you do
wink well coming to one of them anyway
wink are you hitting on its mark that's
exactly all he wants wing okay it's not
is not in the playground bathrooms I'm
in there so go to the other one run away
wrong way makes thanks
now I trusted you game is not about
trust
this is trouble in terrorist town over
again this is oh my god hi how can I
kill any of you if I can't even kill
zombie someone is going to die to a
grenade I think that's a minx
thanks no turn around makes smoke
message no no there's there's a party
going on somewhere and I don't know
where it is
I can see a zombie running really fast
like oh I can see mom no no where is it
oh no don't the water yo don't worry
lovely white shadow mommy I say you
you're you're you're I can size you cuz
you pick the black guy screwed no no
come at me head around ma hey go baby
where's that you way over there huh are
you my buddy Wayne ravaged by zombies my
mommy
what running round in circles like a
play okay so you frigg's like a cap
I was always seriously concerned I was
very concerned
oh yeah we were having a Sambi no that
does not look good
this looks like measures out here coming
at me I don't see anybody
mark why are you know I don't look it
out I'm gonna hook it up mark thanks
over here and everyone's in the corner
no not here screw you five arc uh-huh
nope right thank you come any price
wait no shotgun oh yeah shotgun hey Mark
why we're here madam Oh toran your
mother's a hamster go to like actually
supossed know uh hell is a stamina yo
and that strike yeah you got on you all
right you don't work in the playground
dog okay
I'm hunting a markiplier I'm on his on
his fishy oh why is it good news who
didn't let me blow him up oh god this is
really tense
oh is that is that you that's been
completely who's that McBride I don't I
don't want I don't want fight get all
our fights
oh my god if I die in the bathroom good
look Fenny what comes into all my hey
Tony you to F now by the way do
something about that we gotta head isn't
we got this wait hey Bret well yeah
Brett come to the bathroom
yeah come to the bathroom don't be the
bathroom man one in the pack bras yeah
wait don't you I'm suspicious car the
one in the park I'm in oh yeah yeah oh
the playground yeah I'm in OOP I cannot
fathom they're gonna be covering the bar
it's one of them good well what am i
ready today dear bye
oh my god I'm gonna edge
guys cool no come okay that's room hello
zombies oh you can't do an F mode oh
okay I need a gun I need like it oh hi
ha ha ha I see some happiness going on
over there I'm package no Mitch buzz V
your neck stays very good by the way I
gotta finish him off mark all his way
tonight right here's a quick little
bugger I don't think there anyway no
Joey laughter I guess buddy unless
you're really an okay
are you really edge uh no II should go
huh okay together forever not me then ah
that's what are you guys down goddamn it
I'm killing people with sledgehammers to
stay quiet it's cool it's working all
right
good I help help
forget help I'm sure we're teammates
jammy bastard here we go dig I can't
make friends in a zombie apocalypse when
can I met friends really exactly yeah
what what hi thank you without you how
do you spot back so quickly see this is
what hates this is why I did you like a
daisy because I would always want to be
people friend and they're always like no
we're gonna kill it everyone
ah it isn't a player edges pinned how'd
you get pinned
oh it's just mark and cpk left oh no
it's okay I know how to end the cpk I
got a grenade we'll kill each other
together oh my god several Monday so
much where are you gonna put even if I
die how are they like rice we're gonna
pull the pin out with our teeth and then
kiss with the pinata
tied into a knot in our mouth
oh this is our first day there I'm kind
of Oh
are you back at the Gazebo you use eBay
on all right I got the grenade you ready
that's right
come back come into the gazebo quick
this zombie away I got I got wait wait
I'm coming I'm coming
let's go very jolly this foosball what
did happen nobody here Richard yeah no
this is it it's not the gazebo but it'll
do
I love you people are gonna like totally
[ __ ] you guys hobby market pk yeah I you
get a laptop for traveling and stuff
grant estates and things yes did I have
a laptop that I use it's Anna soos uh
it's one of their gamer model Mandy get
this it yeah you do realize it with
Nokia a sous-sous is how you pronounce
it you mean a useless oh it's a soos
it's a Susan trust me it's a soos it's a
city I used to go to dr. Seuss
I used to call and a representative from
a Seuss told me no it's a Seuss it's
wait wait is this an American
representative yes no people in America
called asus2 and I'm like and I go oh no
it's wrong and they're like [ __ ] you
markiplier you're an idiot
no he's got insider information guys
used to work at an electronics store oh
come on
okay with us gonna play a game you have
to watch the three minutes R it's alive
but comes like a don't you know who I am
I'm the famous on the internet right
manga makes you know you're up here too
now you're you're in the you're in the
elite crowd thank you thank you for the
respect you're showing me yeah you're a
couple steps below me but you know I
still a killer only a third in
oh-oh-oh-oh savior
oh okay okay oh my gosh we go away okay
for his age mystery ever say now okay
one two three thousand um
Oh daisies connecting now let's cool oh
you've dropped 20 years they've dropped
one of your spank pedals minks oh wow oh
god I miss it what did I miss out on in
the first place
it was crazy between my cheeks and I
just like relaxed you can never relax
around zombies get that paddle back in
there okay real really make sure this
this model is based on Yummie cuz he is
a British guy as well
oh yes this he's this handsome I know
wait based on Yummie
hang on let me drop the pants and check
me drop some clothes oh yeah me have to
go forward well that's that's
informative thanks for me Eddie found an
extinguisher now you could put out a
fire points a bringable okay Oh coats's
who's in my white hair okay you guys
want finisher has a hair spray
I guess leading a hot lady to stuff away
my head back fan fiction comments oh
well how do we get through here
oh I'm just did to out your final stings
and now it can put out a fire welcome
yeah thank you for that you didn't see
our spring it so hard to concentrate
when Mac is just spraying white
unbundled mouth I don't think this thing
has a limit I think it's unlimited how
this place - there's doors hair yeah oh
just open every door oh here let me let
me allow me need a sledgehammer
we need a sledgehammer for this I got it
I remember you can hit this sledge how
unless you can break it with a gun I'm
not sure I didn't work my plan to shoot
it for ya Bosh Azam be here Chris Bosh
oh [ __ ] okay thanks Mike
you're welcome I'm here to help okay I
guess we go this way is this annoying
yet Hey look another Jung Seng here
someone grab it well okay me too others
a third why do you gotta shower me with
someone get on your knees
hey edge of this love action giggles
breakfast you want you wanna be a big
youtuber don't you just let me get out
how did you make the top slice LaHood's
is fine vinegar I just love the way
you're holding the fires dude it was
like just den Anna and Dan Donna wait
Mike's gonna sell like burnin up burnin
up rooms right I lean in the way with
this great white earn enough got our own
human marks it's awesome back Vanna dah
dah dah dah dah dah dah dah dah
wait honestly what friendships aren't
formed around foam that's a zombie yeah
quick cover with foam oh my gosh my twin
its twin
no okay no I'm gonna get scope the
toilet hands icing I can't close it okay
whatever just started what are we
watching
no one will be watching I saw burned-out
president this is a privacy screen it's
not what you think this is for privacy
oh let's go Oh Oh y'all done okay hurry
we're good what'd you do
Oh Connors we didn't do anything
maybe it's something in oh my god whoa
minx I just saw a member what inside
someone I saw the inside of your face I
don't mean you my god don't worry but
it's like thirty zombies over that